i’ve done a lot of things to finally get comfortable in my body and like
the person that I am
ironically one of the things that actually helps me
when I'm feeling kinda bad about myself
is thinking about people on Ed Twitter
because they at one point or maybe still use me in my fat body as fat spo
which is basically like
inspiration to starve themselves so they don't look like me
insane anyway
don't go looking for this genuinely
one of the worst parts of the internet anyway
it was like a summer where I spent a lot of time looking at Ed Twitter accounts
because I needed to block all of them
and it made me so sad because no one was good enough for these
even the smallest
thinnest people I've literally ever seen
there was some 15 year old on a private Twitter calling her fat
like that was one of the final times that it clicked for me
as long as I live
there is genuinely nothing that I can do to make everyone like no
if I'm not gonna win why would I even play the game
because I know that there is no possible way for me to live up to that standard
I don't adhere to it at all
and there is something so freeing
about knowing that you will never be good enough for them
genuinely the only thing that you can do is think about how you feel
about how you look
figure out
if you can be comfortable the way you are